Captain America and Iron Man may be
fighting over freedom and justice in
their latest movie but they certainly
won't be arguing over the film's success
I'm Simon and this is a super-powered
Civil War news update the early reviews
for next month's captain america civil
war already among the best that any
marvel movie has received it has now
been predicted that the film is also set
for a huge opening weekend in the box
office according to Variety the third
Captain America movie could earn between
175 and 180 million dollars in its first
three days this figure would place it at
third in the list of Marvel openings
behind the two Avengers films and ahead
of iron man 3 only three films in
history of top 200 million dollars in
their first weekend The Avengers star
wars the force awakens and Jurassic
world when asked about the chances of
civil war joining them media and a list
Eric handler told variety it's tough to
predict any movie getting above 200
million dollars but this one has a shot
they have two weeks of buzz to build on
and the marketing machine behind this is
going to be huge captain america civil
war is directed by Joe and Anthony Russo
and stars Chris Evans Robert Downey jr.
Anthony Mackie Scarlett Johansson and
jeremy renner it is released on May the
5th 2016 will you be watching the
super-powered punch up or are you
suffering from comic book film fatigue
let me know in the comments below or
come find me on Twitter I'm at the j
connaught thanks for watching and for
all your entertainment news keep it
gamespot